Uh, (617) 830-4750 is the number.
Let's go next to our color from the nine one
nine area code.
Who's calling today from nine one nine.
Is this me, David?
That is you.
Fantastic.
Hey David.
My name's Joe.
I am from Raleigh, North Carolina.
And I actually had a quick, I had a quick
question for you.
I heard a rumor that I could not find out
online.
Were you ever a student of Professor Richard
Wolf?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mentioned that in almost every one of my
interviews with him.
I had him for introductory macro at the University
of Massachusetts in 2000 it must have been
2003 I guess.
Oh Wow.
So that leads into my question, how are you
still capitalists, man?
The guy's barely in the way.
He explains, um, how he wants to implement
socialism.
And I would assume that you're not so ardently
against his concept of like worker cooperatives,
right?
No, no.
I have no problem with worker co-ops at all.
I mean, listen, do you have, does having one
class with someone in college make you fully
buy into the full extent of their ideology?
I don't.
I mean, I don't, I don't think so.
Like I had his class.
I'm more or less, I'm more, I'm more or less,
I was being a little blip obviously, but I'm
just explaining that I really do think that
his idea of converting over to a worker cooperative
style form of socialism is what an ideal system
that I would want.
And I was curious what your, um, problem would
be with converting to that kind of a style
of system where we take out this connection
between employer and employee and his entire
concept conception of what socialism.
I'm all for democratizing the workplace.
I think that for any company that wants to
do that and believes that that's how it would
be best run, like that's fantastic.
And there are companies that have done it
and it works for them.
There are companies that have done it and
then have changed their minds cause it didn't
work so well.
I'm completely open to all of that.
But my broader economic view is social democracy,
where democratization of individual workplaces
is great, but I still, um, am okay with a
system that is a very well regulated redistributive
form of capitalism, which is not what we have
here in the United States to be clear.
Right.
Um, so my question would be is I don't understand
what is inherent in capitalism to that exactly.
What exactly is inherent scaffolding that
you would like to keep?
Well, if you're wanting to, I, so when I look
at, if you look at any of the pieces that,
um, uh, sort of distinguish free market capitalism,
real social democracy and an actual socialist
system when it comes to private property,
when it comes to taxation, when it comes to
entrepreneurship and, and private business,
uh, I align with social democracy, which is
an extremely well-regulated form of capitalism.
Not with socialism.
I mean, I guess we're sort of like, we're,
we're going circular here in a sense, but
I've sort of outlined my views on this and
we're,
well, I know, I know, I'm sure you're aware
that like marks distinguishes between, you
know, personal property and private property.
And not necessarily,
yes, he does
the, you know, like a fundamental, like the
state with like not like a Soviet style system.
That's not what a lot, you know, most people
would advocate for.
I think most of those shows would advocate
for like community land grants.
Um, like I said, worker cooperative style
programs.
Like for example in Italy I think they have
something to the effect of like you like nine
people can get together and um, take their,
all their total amount.
They would get in social welfare for that
year and start a worker cooperative.
Like those would be the kinds of programs
that socialists would want here.
So I once again, I'm not quite understanding
what,
yeah, so listen, let me go to that example.
I am not in favor of the government saying
if you start a business and you hire at anyone,
that business now must be shared ownership
with everybody you hire.
Like I find that to be an authoritarian imposition
from government.
So I'm all for businesses deciding that's
what they want to do.
I'm all for people going into business together,
et cetera.
But I would not be for a government saying
any businesses that are started need to have
a, you know, a socialized ownership like that.
I, I'm just not for that.
Okay.
I understand that.
I think that that that would be more of an
option cause like I said, if you're giving,
if the government's just giving you a grant
to do something, it's not necessarily a forcing.
You don't force the structure of that either.
You can do a different forms of socialized
structure within that system.
So I understand your, your concept of that.
But I, I appreciate you taking the call that
I've been actually trying to follow you for
almost three weeks straight on that I asked
you this question.
I really appreciate you taking my call day.
All right.
Thank you.
Yes, it can be tough to get on, but I'm glad
that you did and appreciate the phone call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones.
Don't hang up if you're holding, don't hang
up if you're holding, because I am going to
take more calls right after this.